Vous allez à nouveau devoir lire
et deviner l'origine du poème.
Poème 1 : Drapeaux rouges la raison pour de beaux drapeaux. / Et rubans.
Rubans de drapeaux / Et matière portable / Des raisons de porter une matière. (...)
Poème 2 : Un cerf blessé saute plus haut,/ J'ai entendu la jonquille
J'ai entendu le drapeau ce-jour / J'ai entendu dire le chasseur ; /
Ce n'est rien que l'extase de la mort, / Puis le frein est presque rompu. (...)
Temps écoulé.
Levez la main si vous pensez que le premier est d'un humain.
Levez la main si vous pensez que le second est d'un humain.
Il y a beaucoup plus de personnes.
Vous serez surpris d'apprendre que le premier poème
a été écrit par la poètesse humaine Gertrude Stein.
Et le second poème a été généré par l'algorithme RKCP.
Avant de continuer, je vais décrire rapidement et simplement
le fonctionnement de RKCP.
RKCP est un algorithme créé par Ray Kurzweil,
qui est directeur de l'ingénierie chez Google
et un fervent croyant en l'intelligence artificielle.
Vous donnez un texte source à RKCP,
il analyse le texte source afin de comprendre l'utilisation du langage,
ensuite il régénère un langage
qui imite ce premier texte.
Le poème que nous venons de voir,
le second, qui était, selon vous, écrit par un humain,
a été nourri par un lot de poèmes
de la poètesse Emily Dickinson.
Il a analysé son utilisation du langage,
a appris le modèle,
puis généré un modèle suivant la même structure.
Ce qu'il est important de savoir sur RKCP
est qu'il ne connaît pas le sens des mots qu'il emploie.
La langue est une matière première,
cela pourrait être du chinois, du suédois,
ou encore les mots collectés sur votre fil d'actualités Facebook du jour.
C'est une matière première.
Et pourtant, il est capable de créer un poème
qui semble plus humain que celui de Gertrude Stein,
et Gertude Stein est humaine.
Ce que nous avons fait est plus ou moins un test de Turing inversé.
Gertrude Stein, qui est humaine, est capable d'écrire un poème
qui fait croire à la majorité des juges humains
qu'il a été écrit par un ordinateur.
Ainsi, selon la logique inverse du test de Turing,
Gertrude Stein est un ordinateur.
(Rires)
Vous êtes perdus ?
Je pense que c'est normal.
Jusqu'ici nous avons eu des humains écrivant comme des humains,
des ordinateurs écrivant comme des ordinateurs,
des ordinateurs écrivant comme des humains,
mais nous avons aussi, et c'est le plus déroutant,
des humains écrivant comme des ordinateurs.
Que tirons-nous de cela ?
Que William Blake est, d'une façon, plus humain
que Gertrude Stein ?
Ou que Gertrude Stein est plus ordinateur que William Blake ?
(Rires)
Ce sont les questions que je me pose
depuis environ deux ans,
et je n'ai aucune réponse.
Mais j'ai eu différents aperçus
de notre relation à la technologie.
La première chose est que, pour une raison quelconque,
nous associons à la poésie au fait d'être humain.
Donc quand nous demandons si un ordinateur peut écrire de la poésie,
nous demandons également
la signification du fait d'être humain
et comment délimiter cette catégorie.
Comment dire qui ou quoi fait partie de cette catégorie ?
C'est une question essentiellement philosophique
qui n'admet pas une réponse grâce à un test binaire,
comme le test de Turing.
Je pense qu'Alan Turing comprenait cela
quand il a conçu son test en 1950,
c'était une provocation philosophique.
La seconde chose est que, en passant le test de Turing pour la poésie,
nous ne testons pas la capacité des ordinateurs,
les algorithmes générant de la poésie
sont simples et existent depuis les années 50.
Ce que nous faisons est plutôt
de collecter des opinions sur la signification de l'humanité.
J'ai découvert que,
nous l'avons vu plus tôt,
nous disions que William Blake est plus humain
que Gertrude Stein.
Bien sûr, cela ne veut pas dire que William Blake
est vraiment plus humain
ou que Gertrude Stein est plus un ordinateur.
Cela signifie que la catégorie de l'humain est instable.
Cela m'a permis de comprendre
que l'humanité n'est pas une vérité rigide.
Mais est plutôt quelque chose qui se construit avec nos opinions
et qui évolue dans le temps.
Finalement, je pense qu'un ordinateur fonctionne plus ou moins
comme un miroir qui reflète l'idée de l'humain
que nous lui montrons.
Nous lui montrons Emily Dickinson,
il nous rend Emily Dickinson.
Nous lui montrons William Blake,
il nous le reflète en retour.
Nous lui montrons Gertrude Stein,
nous récupérons Gertrude Stein.
Plus que toute technologie,
l'ordinateur est un miroir
qui reflète l'idée de l'humanité que nous lui inculquons.
Nombre d'entre vous ont dû récemment entendre
parler énormément d'intelligence artificielle.
Et le cœur de la conversation est :
pouvons-nous la créer ?
Pouvons-nous créer un ordinateur intelligent ?
Pouvons-nous créer un ordinateur créatif ?
Ce que nous demandons sans cesse est :
pouvons-nous créer un ordinateur ressemblant à un humain ?
Nous venons de voir
que l'humanité n'est pas un fait scientifique,
que c'est une concaténation d'idées qui change
et évolue perpétuellement avec le temps.
Quand nous commençons à débattre de l'idée
d'une intelligence artificielle dans le futur,
nous ne devrions pas juste nous demander
si nous pouvons la créer
mais nous devrions nous demander
quelle idée de l'humain nous voulons refléter.
C'est une idée essentiellement philosophique,
qui ne peut trouver de réponse avec juste un logiciel
mais qui requiert un moment de réflexion existentielle de notre part à tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)